[Music]  Abby Lee Miller opens up about former  Dance Moms star Maddie Ziegler's huge  success I don't think had she not been  in my studio she would be where she is  today in the Abby tells all Dance Moms  special that aired on Tuesday  the reality star got candid about her  relationship with her former student I'm  not gonna say that I made anybody I  didn't make her her mom and dad created  her but I certainly added my two cents  in since leaving Dance Moms Maddie has  starred in several of singer Sia's music  videos performing with her during public  appearances and attending several  red-carpet events most recently Maddie  made her silver screen debut you okay  I'm good  they're not sad sad no disappointed  absolutely cuz that's not the kid I  raised though Abby says she's not spoken  to the 14 year old dancer she did admit  this I hope that she doesn't forget the  good times because there were a lot more  good times the bad times  [Music]  you